du kannst ja vielleicht einmal ran da
irgendwas auf irgendein unterschied
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video sollte ich hoffe
natürlich jedes gut danke mir auch da
mein letztes airport video eigentlich
ziemlich gut angekommen ist da habe ich
so den besten airport ersatz aus china
getestet also da haben wir zuschauer
geschrieben ja alex checker smart dessen
zu airports die haben 16 euro gekostet
ich habe die bestellt einfach mal
getestet und ich muss sagen die haben
auf jeden fall ganz gut abgeschnitten
falls ihr das video noch nicht gesehen
habt könnt ihr euch das auf jeden fall
hier nach reinziehen oder meinetwegen
auch hier vor
wir haben hier sogar eine kleine
chinesische beschreibung dabei geht es
in ziemlich vielen verschiedenen farben
filme die hier in meiner heimat war das
ging echt gar nicht klar aber sobald man
musik hört natürlich ist das
sounderlebnis jetzt nicht so krass wie
bei diesen hier trotzdem würde ich sagen
für 14 euro 85 übertrifft es absolut
meine vorstellung also ich hätte gedacht
dass wir schlechter ich kann euch einen
guten vergleich dazu sagen und zwar
hören die sich genauso an wie alle
kopfhörer die ich früher benutzt habt
bevor ich apple kopfhörer bekommen hat
mit denen nicht jeden morgen zur schule
gefahren bin und das waren keine app und
daraufhin kam dann ein deutsches ich
würde sich sagen unternehmen aber einen
deutsche verkäufer auf mich zu und
meinte jung
alex ich habe hier auch eher post sie
nennen sich irgendwie flair potts oder
so ähneln eins zu eins im original und
ich würde sagen wir gucken uns mal ganz
kurz die website an was die da so
schreiben ist glaube ich ganz
interessant und die werde ich dann heute
mal testen ich meine die liegen
preislich zwischen 50 und 60 euro oder
so also gar nicht mal so günstig soll
wohl ganz gut sein habe ich so
mitbekommen und ich finde dafür kein
geld oder sonstiges also ich habe
einfach nur das produkt bekommen wenn
ich scheiße ist leicht das auch und wenn
es gut ist sagt das auch deswegen so
leute also das ist die seite von denen
seht ihr hier eingeblendet kabellos
einfach stylish also ich muss sagen seid
ihr gefällt mir gut genau und hier die
modelle einmal originals für knapp 50
euro
und dann hatten wir aber auch noch mehr
produkte warten
hier genau genau man kann auch das pro
modell auswählen und liegt dann hier bei
knapp 70 euro das sind dann die die
wireless charging haben weist die
kanzlei doch auf diese ladebox tun also
eigentlich genau wie bei apple die am
märz auch nun aktuelleres modelle
herausgebracht was auch so funktioniert
da ich zufälligerweise genau dieses
modell letztens irgendwann mal bestellt
hat war apple hat mich das 180 euro
gekostet also wenn die genauso
funktionieren sollten spart man 110
ob das der fall ist probieren wir es mal
aus ich würde sagen wir packen die mal
ganz entspannt aus ich habe hier auch
einmal die originalen airports von apple
ist jetzt nicht das wireless charging
modell kann man halt mit apple anschluss
laden also die haben halt leider noch
nicht dieses wireless charging gut jetzt
schauen wir uns das mal an ich habe
natürlich schon mal reingeschaut
weil es mich interessiert hat und man
muss sagen
hier steht zwar nicht er kurz drauf aber
es ist okay es ist eins zu eins also
guckt mal krass oder
also das war wirklich bis jetzt bei
allen modellen nicht getestet habe auch
die damals von misch da war die
verpackung auf fast identisch nur das
produkt fotos ein bisschen anders aus
und hier haben wir jetzt halt auch
einfach das gleiche produkt
nein daniel hier fehlt was fehlt mir
fehlt was stimmt das nicht okay leute
ich habe mich vertan hier fehlt doch was
kommt hier bei den originalen sind hier
noch so öffnung die haben wir hier nicht
und hier ist ein schwarzer punkt aber
sonst wie das ziemlich gleich aus was
sie noch ganz gut sagen wollte bevor es
weiter wählt und zwar hat mir um diese
firma flair post geschrieben seit
einigen monaten nichts dass ein motor
seit einigen monaten tüfteln wir
gemeinsam mit unserem hersteller an
einzigartigen bluetooth kopfhörern
welche unsere grund begeistern
gerne würden wir ihnen ein kostenloses
exemplar zu stellen und so weiter also
ich dachte erst mal so dass das ist eine
deutsche firma gegen deutschland
airports produzieren will die aber schön
fotoqualität sein
dann habe ich aber diese tracking id für
den versand bekommen und habe dann
gesehen okay sie kommen auch aus china
also genauso wie von mensch und sogar
auch mal diese shenzen steht da immer
besser also inwiefern hier jetzt
deutsche qualität mit dabei ist
wahrscheinlich eher weniger ich hab ich
mal kurz auf das modell aus dem letzten
video wollt wir haben hier die tws 12
hier hinten steht auch etwas von tbs
drauf allerdings was mir auffällt von
der verpackung her ist das auf jeden
fall hochwertiger ganz klar das merkt
man richtig deswegen will jetzt gar
nicht allzu lange auf die folter spannen
wir machen wir jetzt mal aufrichtige ein
kommentar von euch nicht auf die folter
spannen so bist du bereich ich mach das
mal zur kamera im auto kitt ich habe
gegen schwarz bekommen eigentlich neues
und ich mache jetzt hier einfach mal so
ein ganz stumpfen vergleicht wir haben
jetzt einmal die flyer post für ich weiß
nicht ob das modell für 50 oder 70 euro
ist und wir haben die originalen
airports und wenn man das hier auf macht
kummer für euch hört sich das jetzt
wahrscheinlich so als wäre das komplett
gleich muss allerdings sagen das ist
hier deutlich gesagt sag ich jetzt mal
wenn man das versteht als hier also hier
ist ein bisschen weiß nicht aber es ist
auf jeden fall deutlich besser als bei
dem modell die tws 12 die wir beim
letzten mal hatten
da war es komplett schlecht also ich bin
an sich der erste eindruck ist in
ordnung ja kommentieren wir auch hier
die lampe und nicht da drin ist ja gut
nehme ich mal einen raus ich nehme auch
ein von den originalen raus dann schauen
wir uns das noch mal an
bevor wir die gleichen ressort packen
und dann war festen ich bin wirklich so
ich bin richtig gespannt über die
qualität du kannst ja vielleicht einmal
ran so fällt da irgendwas auf
irgendeinen unterschied fehlt ein
löffler in form stimmt ist das für was
ist das für bass oder mikrofon ich weiß
nicht ganz genau wenn ihr das wissen
leute schreibt gerne in die kommentare
ich würde mal vermuten dass es halt
vielleicht ein externer bass und hier
kommt die hohen töne raus oder halt
andersrum kann auch sein
ich muss so eher sagen diese hier haben
so eine leicht ganz leicht raue
oberfläche was ich auf jeden fall
qualitativ gut anfühlt schwierig zu
erklären aber ist nicht schlecht nur
hier hast du das das ist halt also nicht
so gut wie hier nicht nicht so gut
hinein also das lade case na ja wir
haben hier auch wieder ein ios ladegerät
und hier noch eine kleine beschreibung
natürlich auf chinesisch also da kann
man ganz klar sagen das geschäftsmodell
von denen ist es dieses aus china in dem
deutschen markt mit deutscher sprache zu
verkaufen dann sag ich mal so was gar
nicht schlecht ist also das ist auf
jeden fall schlagen würde ich genauso
machen aber man kann auf keinen fall
sagen dass es irgendwie in deutschland
produziert wurde sonst was aber das
haben sie auch nicht gesagt wie kommerz
zur wichtigsten sache heute und zwar zum
audio test raubt es gut ist oder nicht
ich bin extrem gespannt
soll ich vielleicht erst mal noch mit
denen mit den anderen airports einmal
hören oder direkt mit den ersten minuten
erst mit dem guttenberg also dass hier
sind meine standard airports mit denen
ich immer musik höre
wir hören jetzt erst mal einen geilen
song und den gleichen song höre ich dann
auch mit diesen kopfhörern
okay das reicht meist und jetzt kommen
wir zu den schleier ports sowie
connecten die maschinell dafür drücken
wir einfach hinten auf den knapp da
jetzt okay ich finde es kassel kann man
das sieht hier auch genauso also das war
bei den andern ist dass man hier den
arsch das einnehmen kann man soll also
ist schon mal ein gutes zeichen so und
jetzt bin ich gespannt liegen etwas
anders im ohr aber auf jeden fall gut
sieht man dass sie das seht dass
heftiger aus als mit dem land sieht man
das sieht man das heck sieht man das ja
in der nächsten folge machen wir mal ab
und zu gibt es schon aus dem hersteller
von oder leute wenn ihr ein hersteller
kennt bombardier die zusagte airports
alle zu alex er testete und jetzt hört
das gleiche lied ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
er hat mich überzeugt dass auch mal
recht nicht mir sondern qualität in
short also im juli hat der kamera ist
sehr musikalisch ist auch erfolgreicher
dj und er sagt auch dass das nicht so
meistens ich will natürlich jetzt die
marke flyer paulson nicht schlecht reden
aber ich muss wirklich sagen zum
beispiel dieses modell hier hat 16 euro
gekostet glaube ich oder 15 euro
ich hab's aus china bestellt und vom
sound her war das ähnlich ich will jetzt
nicht sagen dass diese hier besser waren
aber zum wirklichen unterschied konnte
ich da nicht erkennen
deswegen es tut mir leid dass jetzt
sagen zu müssen aber 50 oder 60 euro
dafür ist schon ein bisschen viel
also mein fazit dazu ist wenn ihr
airports haben wollte und nicht 118 oder
150 euro für die originalen bezahlen
wollte schaut euch lieber auf
irgendwelchen häkchen hinsicht seiten um
und diese hier waren auf jeden fall
schon ganz gut 15 euro in ort und meiner
meinung nach leute ich hab leider über
eine kabellose ladestation für apple
nicht mehr ist ein bisschen blöd obwohl
da kann man auch samsung drauflegen und
alles ich habe einfach ein 7er kann ich
mich auch nicht mit aus aber ich hole
mir zweiter lief deswegen konnte ich
jetzt nicht testen ob das funktioniert
wir gehen jetzt aber einfach mal davon
aus ist ja auch egal ob 50 oder 70 euro
sind sagen wir mal das handy für 50 euro
ist auch relativ viel geld finde ich
dafür wie gesagt ich glaube da gibt es
ein paar andere alternativen
auch wenn ich es cool finde wenn man als
deutscher starter war so versucht so ein
paar airports zu verkaufen also die
seite von den bau auf jeden fall sehr
gut aufgebaut und so das produkt nach
wende habe jetzt nicht so gefeiert
falls ihr irgendwelche erb und
hersteller kennt schreibt denn gerne
alex prugh alle airports und dann
schauen wir was beim nächsten video
testen können
morgen um 20 uhr sehen wir uns wieder
gibt's neues video statement surprise
alex wie zschau